President Trump held a rally with
supporters last night in Pennsylvania
and said nothing about his
administration's vowed to protect this
year's election from Russian meddling
top national security officials laid out
their strategy yesterday saying they
were acting on the president's orders
weezer jiang is near the New Jersey Golf
Club where mr. Trump is starting a
10-day vacation we should good morning
good morning Nora the Trump
administration's display followed a
period of tension between President
Trump and his intelligence community
because he sided with Vladimir Putin in
Helsinki but this morning he faces new
questions about why for his part it's as
though this new show of force against
Russia hadn't happened they wanted me to
walk up and go like this president Trump
once again defended his summit with
Vladimir Putin and slammed the Russia
investigation during a campaign rally in
Pennsylvania he did not bring up
Moscow's ongoing interference in u.s.
election even though just hours earlier
president has made it very clear I think
what his priority is the president's
national security chiefs delivered a
full-court press to address what they
called a pervasive campaign by Russia to
weaken and divide the United States we
acknowledge the threat it is real it is
continuing and we're doing everything we
can to have a legitimate election our
democracy itself is in the crosshairs
FBI director Christopher ray laid out
many methods of attack they have
uncovered manipulating news stories
spreading disinformation leveraging
economic resources and escalating
divisive issues Secretary of Defense
James Madison's Department is taking
active measures to protect election
security including monitoring our
adversaries the head of the US Cyber
Command said they are prepared to take
action to I won't discuss the specifics
except to state that our forces are
well-trained ready and very capable the
ranking Democrat on the Senate
Intelligence Committee said he was fine
glad to see that the White House is
doing something about election security
but quickly added if only it was backed
up by something the president has said
or done just a short time ago the White
House wanted to stress it is important
to the president even though he did not
mention the briefing at his rally
Anthony we just thanks